Now let's make sure that we understand the benefits of
object orientation through a quiz. Imagine that acme corporation decided
to use an objetory entered approach in its software development
process. If this is the case what benefits can they expect
to receive from this decision. And here I'm listing some
possible benefits. Increased reuse because of the modular cooling style.
Increased maintainability because the system design can accommodate changes more
easily. Increased speed because object oriented systems tend to run faster.
And increased understandability because the
design models real world entities. So,
I would like, as usual, for you to mark all that apply.